Speaker 1: This next story requires some explanation,
but it's pretty fascinating.
A couple of days ago, Tucker Carlson, Fox
News propagandist, ran a kind of strange out
of place commentary on his show where he vaguely
referred to his college yearbooks and people
like Jeff Bezos looking for dirt on Tucker
Carlson.
And it was weird because it was just out of
context.
It seemed to have nothing to do with what
was going on on Tucker's show.
And it raised the question of whether Tucker
Carlson was trying to get ahead of a maybe
embarrassing or problematic story.
So let's start by taking a look at that.
This is the clip from a couple of nights ago,
just kind of out of nowhere.
We don't know what this was about.
Speaker 4: We're going to get a quick piece
of news from the world of big tech.
We spent the day hearing from quite a few
old college classmates.
In some cases people would be out of touch
with for 30 years.
It was nice, but here was the occasion for
it.
Jeff Bezos had one of his minions, a mentally
unbalanced, middle aged man called Erik Wemple,
poor, dusty college yearbook and call around
to see if we've done anything naughty at the
age of 19.
That sounds like fun.
Let us know if you hear any good stories.
But before Bezos drops any more of his billions
on opposition research, you should know that
it will not affect any election outcome.
This is a news show.
It's not a political campaign.
No one here is running for anything or plans
to.
On the other hand, if Jeff Bezos wants to
come over to reminisce about nineteen eighty
seven on this show, he's always welcome anytime.
Speaker 1: Sort of a strange story in a vacuum.
But then yesterday it all starts to become
much clearer.
An image purporting to be Tucker Carlson's
college yearbook entry from Trinity College
in nineteen ninety one mentions that Tucker
was part of a number of groups, including
the Christian Fellowship, OK, the Jesse Helms
Foundation, and something called the Dan White
Society.
Now, for those wondering whether this is even
a real image, Trinity College has confirmed
that this is their real 1991 yearbook.
Tucker's entry is on page 186.
There is no question about it being real.
And this started to raise some questions because
the Dan White society references Dan White.
Dan White was the guy who killed San Francisco
Mayor George Moscone and Supervisor Harvey
Milk, California's first openly gay elected
official in 1978.
Dan White was a horrible person, a disgustingly
violent, homophobic person.
And so when you look at Tucker's yearbook
and it says Dan White society, that's starting
to look not so good.
And then our longtime friend, Jeremy Hooper
did some more research into this and found
a 1990 op ed by Tucker Carlson in his college
newspaper where he calls homosexuality, quote,
unnatural and unhealthy.
And it is signed TSM Carlson and indeed, Jeremy
confirmed that Tucker Carlson is the only
possible student with those initials at that
time.
It also appears, as Jeremy Hooper points out
on Twitter, that this is the only thing Tucker.
Ever wrote in the newspaper, meaning it's
not that Tucker was a regular columnist and
it just so happened that one day he wrote
about unnatural gay people, he went out of
his way to write one column one time about
his displeasure with the fact that gay people
exist now.
To me, this is less about whether Tucker Carlson
was homophobic in 1990 or 1991 as a sort of
potential disqualifier for Tucker to do whatever
today.
First of all, there's tons of people that
are homophobic.
Secondly, I don't think being homophobic is
considered a problem for Fox News host.
That may even it may be a feature more than
it is a bug.
And third, most importantly, in theory, Tucker's
views may have changed over the last 30 years.
I have views that are different today than
they were 30 years ago.
And much like I would say about anyone if
these were Tucker's views 30 years ago, and
they appear to be, it doesn't necessarily
tell us how his views are today.
Many of my views have changed, although I
was never anti-gay.
It's more about the strange nature of how
Tucker ended up getting into this story earlier
this week, doing this bizarre Proactiv segment
to attack Jeff Bezos and to say people are
looking for dirt.
It's just all very strange.
Now, that being said, yeah, Tucker's heroes
in college were really disturbing.
It's not just that of the three groups he
mentions, one seems to be an adoration of
the guy who killed Harvey Milk for being gay.
That's horrifying.
He also shouts out Jesse Helms.
Jesse Helms used to be a senator who opposed
the Civil Rights Act, opposed the Voting Rights
Act, called the Civil Rights Act, dangerous
and on and on.
If these were Tucker's heroes, then I'd be
curious as to who his heroes are today.
It's really horrible stuff.
I don't expect much more to come of it.
You know, anybody thought, oh, he should be
fired from Fox News.
Yeah, right.
Even if Fox News doesn't see this as a feature,
it's not going to cause a problem for Tucker
on Fox News, but a very strange story and
watching it develop it, watching it develop
over the week.
Even stranger with the Proactiv.
Oh, people are calling around looking for
dirt on me.
Really weird.
Let me know what you make of it